The National Institute of Standards and
Technology, which adapted a definition
for cloud computing in 2011 also
defined different types of clouds.
The first dimension how
clouds are classified
is based on the deployment models.
Clouds can be public like
Amazon's EC2 cloud is a public cloud.
And this is a cloud where
the infrastructure belongs to the cloud
provider.
However, third party customers or
tenants,
anyone with a credit card really,
can come in and run their services,
their infrastructure,
on top of Amazon's own hardware.
Clouds can be private.
I said earlier that Amazon
used the same type of
technology that they opened
up as Amazon Web Services.
They used it originally
internally to enable elastic and
dynamic provisioning of the physical
infrastructure across the different
types of applications and services
that Amazon internally executes.
In the case of a private cloud,
it is the infrastructure
as well as the tenants,
the services, the applications, that
are run on top of that infrastructure.
Everything is owned by
the same entity and
it's just cloud computing technology is
used to enable some of the provisioning
and the elasticity that cloud
computing offers to applications.
Then there is a hybrid cloud as
a possible deployment model.
This is a scenario where a private
cloud is interfaced with some public
cloud where these public resources
are used either for failover for
some additional redundancy,
for dealing with spikes.
I know of certain companies who
choose these public resources
to run simulated workloads
that would then generate
supposed request patterns on top of
their, privately run core services.
Finally the definition also
references that there is a community
cloud as a type of cloud.
This is really just a public cloud
where the third party customers or
the third party users of the services or
the information that's provided by this
community cloud, isn't really just
used by arbitrary customers but
by a certain type of users.